does look like now we're in the early
stages of another wave of covid the long
predicted Autumn wave scientists had
said this would come and since the
beginning of September the numbers have
been increasing
according to the office for National
statistics in the week to the 24th of
September 1.3 million people in the UK
are estimated to have had the virus
that's a 25 increase on the week before
and it's rising in every part of the UK
so in Northern Ireland it's about one in
40 people in Scotland one in 45 and in
England and Wales it's about 1 in 50 and
you can expect those numbers to increase
week on week for a little while yet
foreign
there has been a sharp rise in the
number of people who are going into
hospital with covid at the beginning of
September it was about 500 a day at the
end of September it was about 1100 a day
so a very steep rise what has been a
feature particularly about Omicron and
as people have become more likely to
have had a vaccine you're seeing people
going in with covid rather than because
of covid so they're there for a
different medical reason if you look at
death rates of course it takes a while
for these new infections in this Autumn
wave to feed through to the mortality
rates and at the moment the numbers are
actually going down it's around 30
people a day who are dying if you look
at the death certificates as a result of
covid and that's much much less than at
the beginning of the year when it was
about 1200 a day so we're nowhere near
that and to be perfectly honest we're
unlikely to get back to those kinds of
levels and unless of course there is a
really nasty variant lurking around the
corner
[Music]
certainly is that we've been locked up
for so long that because of kovid that
flu has virtually disappeared around the
world for the last few years and that
means there are immunity to flu is much
lowered so the concern is that we might
get hit by this twin demic combination
of high covid rates and high flu rates
both at the same time both viruses
taking advantage of low immunity and
that could lead to serious problems for
the NHS because you would have a very
large number of people coming in
potentially and that would occupy beds
that are needed to get rid of the
backlog that waiting list of people
needing care for other medical
conditions that has built up over the
the long pandemic years
if you're feeling unwell you stay at
home just as you would do with any other
disease but there's no requirement to do
so once you've feeling much better you
can go back to work you can mix with
with other people of course you may
choose not to and you should certainly
bear in mind that there are some people
who are very vulnerable to Serious
disease and take precautions with them
can you confirm your date of birth so UK
Health Security Agency is really
encouraging people to come forward now
at the moment it's everybody over the
age of 50 is going to be called forward
for an Autumn booster and they say it is
utterly essential that we do with low
immunity and high rates of of covid now
as cases rise then that is a combination
that the NHS is really not going to want
to see becoming a feature in the months
ahead
if there's one thing we've learned
through all the waves of Cove it is that
you should never look too far into the
future it is a virus that is very
difficult to predict now it's entirely
possible that everybody comes forward
gets their Jabs and we get through this
with no big problem and the hope is we
can continue doing that through this
winter the risk is if people don't come
forward for their Jabs then that will
lead to more serious infections and that
will cause problems for the NHS and of
course if that happens to to Great an
extent then there will be calls for
masks to return and so on I can't see
that happening if people come forward
for the vaccine it is a good vaccine it
has got us out of this mess could
continue keeping us out this mess if we
come forward for the Jabs when we're
called